Robert Buchanan was born in Nova Scotia, Canada,
in 1862.
Together with his wife and young daughter,
he moved to New York City in 1886 to practice
medicine.
By the summer of 1890, he had divorced his
wife and was “becoming acquainted” with
a relatively wealthy woman 20 years his senior,
who ran a house of prostitution in Newark,
New Jersey.
Within the year, Anna and Buchanan were married.
The two lived on West 11th Street in New York
City, although Buchanan hid the marriage and
represented to the world that she was just
his housekeeper.
The two fought a lot and by the end of 1891,
she threatened to leave him.
During that winter, Buchanan frequently told
friends that “the old hag” was unbearable,
and that he had to “get rid of her no matter
what it cost.”
Two years earlier, a medical student, Carlyle
Harris, had been convicted of killing his
wife with morphine when it was shown that
she had the telltale “pinpointing of the
pupils” that occurs with a morphine overdose.
During February 1892, Buchanan discussed this
case with many acquaintances and frequently
referred to Harris as a “stupid amateur”
and “bungling fool,” as well as that he
(Buchanan) knew how to eliminate the tiny
pupils when taking (or giving) morphine.
The day before Anna’s death, Buchanan began
laying his cover story.
He told his friend that she was very sick,
and that he thought she might not survive
(other eyewitnesses countered this claim and
noted she was quite well).
On the fateful day, after eating a hearty
breakfast alone (Buchanan always ate at his
friend’s restaurant), Anna suddenly had
such severe pains in her head that she was
unable to stand.
A physician, Dr. McIntyre, arrived shortly
after, but upon examination, opined that she
was suffering from hysteria and prescribed
one teaspoonful of a bromide of sodium every
two hours.
When he returned at 2 p.m. her symptoms were
worse, so he added two drachms of chloral
hydrate to the teaspoon she was to take.
Just after 3 p.m., one of Anna’s friends,
Mrs. Brockway, visited and saw Buchanan giving
Anna two teaspoons of something – a difference
he explained as due to the fact that his spoon
was smaller than the standard size (a fact
disproven in court).
After taking the two teaspoons from Buchanan,
she immediately grimaced and then sucked on
an orange, as if to get rid of a bitter taste.
Within 15 minutes, she fell into a deep sleep
from which she never awoke.
At another point during the day, a nurse noticed
Buchanan bent over Anna, apparently dropping
something in her eyes.
When Dr. McIntyre returned that evening with
another physician, they noted the now comatose
Anna had slow respiration, a rapid pulse,
flushed face, hot and dry skin, and normal
pupils (the right was slightly dilated).
Dr. McIntyre and the other physician both
concluded that she had a stroke.
She died the next day.
Right away, Buchanan’s mood improved.
On the day of her death, he told a friend
that “Providence was smiling upon him,”
and immediately after the funeral, he went
on a pub crawl with his buddies.
Throughout his carousing, Buchanan discussed
how much he had inherited from his wife (by
all accounts $50,000, or about $1.2 million
today).
After a few days, Buchanan went back to Nova
Scotia where he quickly (within 3 weeks of
his wife’s death) remarried his first wife.
Returning to New York, Buchanan discovered
that Ike White, a reporter, had been looking
into the details of Anna’s death.
After digging up most of the dirt in the case,
Ike was able to heckle the authorities into
literally digging up Anna and conducting an
autopsy.
“Wonderfully well preserved,” Anna’s
body held evidence of sufficiently large amounts
of morphine to have done the deed, as well
as evidence of atropine – a drug of the
belladonna family that dilates pupils and
increases heart rates.
The autopsy also revealed that she had not
suffered a stroke or had any disease that
would account for her death.
At trial, Buchanan strongly challenged the
prosecution’s scientific evidence, arguing
that ptomaine, a product of putrefaction,
could be mistaken for morphine and atropine
in chemical tests.
To counter this evidence, the prosecution,
through one of its expert witnesses, put on
its appalling demonstration.
A cat was brought into the courtroom and injected
with a lethal dose of morphine.
As the jury, judge, lawyers and spectators
watched, the cat’s pupils constricted, then
once drops of atropine were applied, dilated.
The cat, of course, died.
Nonetheless, the defense was vigorous, and
since the evidence was only circumstantial,
many court watchers thought Buchanan might
even be acquitted – until he decided to
take the stand.
Self-obsessed and whiny, the prosecution trapped
Buchanan in lie after contradiction after
lie until no one was left with any doubt as
to his guilt.
Dr. Robert Buchanan was executed in the electric
chair in New York’s Sing Sing on July 2,
1895.